[Music]
really is hard to believe that life
could get any better for country music
star Kelsea Ballerini she's got a
wedding on the way and Kelsey is one of
the artists who could have a very good
night this Sunday at the Academy of
Country Music Awards
kelsey is feeling a lot of love these
days three number one country hits a new
fiancee plus she's performing on sundays
ACM Awards with two nominations
including female vocalist of the Year
Miranda Lambert Carrie Underwood what
does it mean to you to be in that
company Carrie like in particular I
wouldn't know what it looks like to be a
female in country music without her you
know sort of be in the category with
someone who's inspired me so much it's
really cool it's really cool Kelsey has
dibs on a hot date for the ACM Awards
red carpet but it's not her fiance
Aussie musician Morgan Evans who are you
bringing to the ACM I think I might
bring my dad yeah he loves Vegas my dad
is like he's 18 years old at heart so
her fiance may be missing from the red
carpet but their wedding plans are in
full swing we're getting closer that the
goal for now is this year and I think in
a neutral area so not Nashville not
Australia are you starting to kind of
get a feel for what you're like as a
bride or like what your style is gonna
be like anything like that be white
that's a Canadian
[Music]
and what you're doing it
and when it comes to sweating for the
wedding Kelsey's got a plan
has it been tough for you to stay in
shape on the road me and my band and
crew we all do like a big group workout
it's got to be hard to stay healthy
though in terms of what you eat you're
always it on the go
it is and catering has a lot to do with
it there's always like a vegan option
and all that stuff not that I always
pick it but it's better but I'm also I'm
never gonna be that girl that's like I'm
gonna cut out carbs for two weeks I
can't do it I do in moderation but I eat
probably a cookie a day Kelsie listen to
me eat everything you can down because
it changes ladies by the way don't
forget the ACS will air this Sunday rtvf
[Music]
you